[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici petit à petit les broussailles et
les épineux laisse place au vert
éclatant des champs cultivés nous sommes
sur le littoral Ouest plus précisément à
Saint-Leu dans cette zone de la Pointe
des Châteaux Nicolas Carpi s'apprête à
récolter prochainement sur cette
parcelle ses premières Cannes un rêve
devenu réalité grâce à l'arrivée de
l'eau d'irrigation bah sans l'eau
surtout sur l'antenne 6 bah sans l'eau
peut rien faire sans l'eau c'était comme
si que on avait rien dans le désert ah
oui dans le désert carrément donc euh
voilà c'est bien c'est avec Nau ben on a
un meilleur rendement avec la r582 et la
r584 mise en place sur la parcelle des
variétés adaptées à la zone Nicolas
espère atteindre un rendement de 120
tonnes de cannes à l'hectare de quoi
conforter toute la famille de ce jeune
agriculteur dans son choix et dans
l'avenir de la filière Canière pour nous
c'est une grande satisfaction et ben
bien sûr avec sans l'aide de l'État de
de l'Europe du conseil général ben rien
ne pourrait se faire aujourd'hui ben on
est
satisfait comme d'autres agriculteurs de
l'antenne 6 cette zone littorale
comprise entre tris bassins et Saint-Leu
Nicolas Carpi a bénéficié d'une aide
financière pour l'aménagement foncier de
son terrain le département cofinance et
préfinance avec le féader à hauteur de
85 % pour les travaux d'aménagement
foncier et pour les études à hauteur de
100 % et les 25 les 15 % restent à la
charge de
dans l'aménagement de la parcelle de
Monsieur Carpi tout ce qui dit épierage
et broyage il y a également la mise en
place d'un bassin de rétenension donc
qui permet de de bloquer le fait de
gérer l'écoulement des eaux
pluviales parallèlement à l'aménagement
des terres qui se poursuit l'irrigation
du littoral Ouest a déjà permis la mise
en valeur dans cette zone de 438
hectares depuis 2007 en 2015 une deuxème
tranche de travaux per ra d'iriguer 333
hectares supplémentaires soit 771
hectares en tout dans ce périmètre de
l'antenne 6 si l'irrigation de l'Ouest
arrive à son terme c'est grâce à un
effort politique et financier soutenu de
la collectivité enfin du conseil général
bien entendu avec une participation
importante de l'Europe avec les fonds
Feder foga
fader c'est toujours un pavant un
meilleur rendement au champ àct et un
meilleur
revenu
[Musique]
jadis couvert d'épineux le littoral de
Saint-Leu se métamorphose chaque jour un
peu plus grâce à l'irrigation de
l'antenne 6 installé sur les hauteurs de
colisçon ctiusia et Olivier paayette se
sont lancés voici 4 ans dans la
production de banane bio un projet
ambitieux que la jeune agricultrice a a
pu concrétiser malgré les difficultés du
départ c'est vrai qu'au début on avait
un petit peu peur mais avant de se
lancer dans le dans le projet on a fait
des essais donc on a on a planté
plusieurs plusieurs choses comme les
mangues les chi l'ANI et la banane et on
a vu que la banane a très bien réussi et
puis c'était plus vite par rapport aux
autres autres arbres fruitiers voilà on
est pratiquement les pionners sur
l'antenne 6 et ben on a on plante la
banane bananerie c'est pas commun dans
l'Ouest normalement c'est dans l'Est
mais avec l'arrivée de l'eau de du
basculement des EAU les bananes dans
l'Ouest maintenant aujourd'hui le jeune
couple exploite près de 3 hectares de
banan Ray ce C terrain pentu et
difficile d'accès c'est vrai que le
terrain sur l'antenne 6 c'est un petit
peu très très pentu même on va dire et
c'est pas toujours évident de travailler
dessus mais bon on s'adapte
voilà on a à peu près entre 8 et 9
parcelles voilà par rapport à la
topographie du terrain donc on peut pas
travailler en un seul tenant donc on a
essayé de faire plusieurs parcelles avec
des endins qui retiennent un peu l'eau
et puis voilà une eau précieuse que ces
agriculteurs prennent également soin de
ne pas gaspiller pour arroser les
bananiers ils ont opté pour un système
d'irrigation par
microaspersion plus adapté à la
configuration de leur terrain parce que
nous on est en terrain vous voyez en
terrain pointu c'est en pente donc pour
éviter l'érosion avec l'eau on fait des
des micropirations que c'est une sorte
de pluie fine respectueux de
l'environnement ctiuscia et Olivier
produisent de la banane bio pour lutter
contre le charançon du bananier ils
utilisent ainsi un piège homologué
contre ce ravageur ce sont des pièges on
va dire fait maison mais dans le
principe c'est quand même un principe
agréé
c'est une bouteille il y a de l'eau
savonneuse à l'intérieur une ouverture
et ensuite des des pastilles de pour
voilà pour attirer le le charonçon donc
lui il va se précipiter il va tomber
dans l'eau savonneuse et il va être
[Musique]
bloqué